global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight eric sorenson
good evening and thanks for joining us
the protests in ottawa are heading into
their second weekend both sides
preparing to make their next moves today
ottawa police said they are shifting
strategy
what ottawa residents have endured what
ottawa businesses have endured
what our own service members and our
partners have endured over the last week
is unacceptable
more police are being brought into the
nation's capital while the protesters
are expecting reinforcements of their
own other cities are also bracing for
protests to bolster the anti-mandate
message and among those joining the
chorus donald trump who in a statement
called prime minister justin trudeau a
far-left lunatic who has destroyed
canada with insane coveted mandates
officials in ottawa of course have been
trying to avoid the kind of mayhem trump
inspired on capitol hill one year ago
but are things about to heat up once
more on parliament hill david aiken
joins us now david
eric police are now preparing for
hundreds more to arrive this weekend to
join the protest or start a counter
protest
this morning we've begun implementing a
new surge and contained strategy in our
downtown core
up till now the strategy of the ottawa
police has essentially been to maintain
the status quo the implication was that
this is just somehow going to magically
de-escalate
[Music]
but researcher regina bateson said that
was wishful thinking based on my
research and based on other similar
events that have unfolded elsewhere and
similar groups i just didn't see any
signs of that actually happening the
liberals new democrats in bq have been
calling for police to end the
demonstration and on friday there was
significant movement inside the
conservative caucus senator dennis
patterson of nunavut appointed by
stephen harper quit the conservative
caucus in disgust a quebec conservative
mp pierre paulus called the
demonstration the siege of ottawa and an
occupation and said the streets should
be cleared of what he called radicals in
anarchists interim leader candace bergen
backed off her full-throated defense of
the protest acknowledging for the first
time that it had to end ottawa police
still have not announced plans to clear
the protests but they did announce some
new measures including an extra 150
police in the downtown core increased
intelligence operations and more
barriers the demonstrators in the red
zone area remain highly organized
well funded
extremely committed to resisting all
attempts to end the demonstration safely
for the first time in decades the
national war memorial has been fenced
off there's no question the dynamics
around who's involved and the different
fractions of different players
that are in town present a real risk and
potential for increased violence
but in the seven days the protesters
have been here they have also adapted
building this hut for example they
intend to use as a kitchen and bringing
in supplies and fuel we have no choice
we will stay here up to the end we have
no choice in addition to the very
visible municipal and provincial police
presence global news has learned that
the rcmp have deployed an emergency
response team or ert that's a
specialized unit with officers trained
to respond to anyone who'd use a weapon
or engage in other incidents of serious
violence eric
david aiken in ottawa thanks
in toronto police are also preparing
ahead of a planned anti-mandate protest
tomorrow
the service will manage these protests
as best we can with the intention to
limit disruption
but our number one priority will be the
safety of the public
parking areas have been designated for
the trucks and protesters while roads
around queens park and nearby hospitals
have been blocked off police say they
want to ensure a peaceful demonstration
and officers assigned to the protest
will wear body cameras
this was winnipeg today one of many
cities where parallel anti-mandate
protests are popping up
plus there were demonstrators today in
calgary
and in southern alberta after nearly a
week many of the protesters near kutz
are digging in for the long haul near a
border crossing rcmp are asking people
to avoid the area
the unrest and frustration in part is a
reflection of the economy omicron has
had an impact on workers across the
country statistics canada is reporting
the largest drop in employment in a year
the economy lost two hundred thousand
jobs last month more than expected amid
stricter public health rules that pushed
the unemployment rate up to 6.5 percent
as ann gaviola explains most of the job
losses were in two provinces that
implemented some of the strictest covet
19 measures
one in 10 canadian workers were out sick
in january a new record that drives home
the omicron waves impact on the job
force and once again canada's most
vulnerable workers were hardest hit
those low-wage workers
are still very unlikely to have paid
sick leave and so they're more likely to
be off sick but less likely to be paid
for it canada's economy shed jobs for
the first time in nearly a year most of
january's job losses were in ontario and
quebec the two provinces hit earliest by
omicron and the two that responded with
the strictest covid measures now most of
the job losses were in hospitality with
sports arenas gyms restaurants and
events shut down or restricted
chair decor supplies linens and
accessories for weddings revenue dries
up every time coveted restrictions take
effect staffing is one of their biggest
challenges and now if we think that
people are going to want to return to
the hospitality industry with zero job
security and a like fourth layout or
whatever lockdown we are in
you know it's going to be slim
picking many workers have left
hospitality and food services after
rounds of layoffs and uncertainty
a lot of workers have found jobs in
other industries and we can understand
why because they all they all have rent
to pay
their families and they need a little
bit more stability
canada still has nearly 1 million job
vacancies and this economist says
immigration needs to be a priority to
help fill that void and with labor
shortages around the world workers have
a lot of options canada risks losing our
own talent on
workers and healthcare and food services
and transportation that we really
desperately need
with inflation running hotter than the
bank of canada's target and the labor
market losing momentum most economists
expect the smallest of rate hikes from
the bank of canada in early march eric
and gaviola in toronto thank you anne
canada's top doctor is calling for a new
approach to covet 19. dr teresa tam says
it's now clear the virus will be with us
for months or years to come and more
sustainable measures are needed to get
back to a normal way of life
further
will occur
um some will actually be quite severe or
disruptive and we need to be ready for
them but we do need to have more longer
term sustained approaches and and
capacity building
so that we're not
in crisis mode all the time
there's new vaccination guidance for
canadians who contract covet 19 the
national advisory committee on
immunization says people who get
infected should wait three months before
getting their booster dose the agency
says waiting may result in a better
immune response
while hospitals across the country have
struggled during the pandemic it's big
cities that tend to get most of the
attention tonight we look at a smaller
facility
the cornwall community hospital in
eastern ontario the cch is giving global
national a look inside and as mike
armstrong discovered covet 19 has
overwhelmed parts of the hospital and
shut down other parts
how many operating rooms do you have
here so we have six operating rooms it
should be busy in these hallways
dr gary weinberg is the chief of surgery
at cornwall community hospital right now
only one of his operating rooms is
running with ontario postponing elective
surgeries five operating rooms are empty
well it's horrible you know it's 1 20 in
the afternoon right now normally this
room should be full of hustle and muscle
patients getting the care they need
all right just relax your arm there
now weinberg says shutting down was like
cutting off an arm to save the rest of
the body very hard choices had to be
made the staff was needed in other parts
of the hospital to keep it going the
acute medicine unit would normally have
12 nurses they've had days where five
were off sick with covid that's a
patient to nurse ratio the director of
the department calls unsafe it has
reached that level knock on wood we're
not there this week you know what i'm
going to check your chart right now in
the hospital 38 staff members are off
sick the rest have already had kovid or
basically they're waiting to get it for
the first time i've been sick
a lot of my co-workers have been sick to
take some of the burden off people like
nurse kelly lauzon for the last few
weeks the hospital has redeployed staff
that would normally be working off-site
this woman's not a nurse she's a
warehouse worker the extra hands were
needed that desperately you know we're
going into year three now of this
exhausting it doesn't seem like there's
any end in sight
pre-pandemic the cch already ran near or
over capacity it used to have 156 beds
it's added 22. it literally says it over
the door yes the auditorium isn't an
auditorium right now it holds 11
patients there's no place to bed space
them anywhere else yeah there's a
struggle in intensive care as well this
fifth wave has been the toughest
so right now we're at 13 patients
admitted to a 12 bed unit
so we're over capacity every day it's
been like way the last few weeks
there are days where every single
patient in this icu is here due to covid
and the unvaccinated are
over-represented one nurse told us she'd
like to give some sort of covered tours
so people could see what's going on but
it would be too dangerous for people to
visit where she works every day
mike armstrong global news cornwall
ontario
atlanta canada is being hit by a large
and unfortunately slow moving storm it's
packing heavy winds and snow and
potentially dangerous amounts of
freezing rain
storm warnings are in place across much
of the region most schools in the
maritimes were closed today because of
the weather environment canada is
warning widespread and extended power
outages are likely
the same storm system is causing chaos
south of the border millions of
americans are being hit and hundreds of
thousands are already without power as
jennifer johnson explains the power
outages couldn't come at a worse time
hundreds of stranded cars and tractor
trailers are slowly starting to move
again on an interstate in central texas
they've been stuck since early thursday
night when icy conditions sent 18
wheelers careening out of control we're
actually coming in from ohio and shot
straight down to avoid the big storm but
then you can't avoid the black ice
travel is hazardous in several states
indiana had to deploy its national guard
to rescue stranded drivers the ice is
the real killer out here around dallas
ice glazed over trees and power lines
leaving 70 thousand in the dark oh no
not again that was my first instinct i'm
going to my mother's to be rescued to
get warm one year ago the state's power
grid froze up for several days the worst
energy infrastructure failure in texas
history more than 200 people died but
the governor is promising the grid is
better winterized now the power grid
continues to perform well at peak demand
during this winter storm
this massive storm 3 700 kilometers long
is also bringing a frigid blast to a
hundred million americans the wintry
mess is causing thousands of flight
cancellations and delays a waiting game
for those desperate to escape we're
going to cancun i don't care what's
happening
the national weather service is warning
of more heavy snow and treacherous ice
conditions as this storm plows its way
up to the northeast
jennifer johnson global news washington
flood proofing the future coming up why
experts are warning canada is not
prepared for more extreme weather
and why a european city is in hot water
over its plan to help billionaire jeff
bezos
flooding in this country has upended
lives brought supply chains to a halt
and cost all of us billions and experts
are warning the costs could skyrocket
even more in the coming years because
canada's infrastructure just isn't ready
this week on the new reality christa
hessie looks at why we're falling behind
and how one city is making real progress
krista
as our bc viewers know all too well
climate change is causing sea levels to
rise and more intense storms
making flooding the most frequent and
costly natural disaster in canada
at risk is the country's most important
infrastructure that's not just our roads
and railways its electricity fuel water
and food supply the basic necessities of
life
new research suggests that communities
across the country big and small are not
equipped for the floods of the future
government flood maps are on average 20
years out of date existing
infrastructure is vulnerable due to
decades of under investment and as the
population increases development is
still happening in flood prone areas up
until just recent years
98 of discussion on the climate file has
focused on mitigating greenhouse gas
emissions which is a smart thing to do
and i'm fully in favor of that but we've
done so to the exclusion of talking
about adaptation the problem with
forward movement on adaptation is that
nobody's in charge of the file
in spite of that one city has made real
strides in flood preparedness edmonton
the city and local utility are flood
proofing homes and building new
infrastructure
that's made it one of canada's best
prepared cities to withstand powerful
storms it's not going to come cheap but
it's going to save us
you know billions of dollars in
insurance premiums and and avoidable
losses
as well as a lot of heartache and a lot
of disruption to families and businesses
we got a close-up view of what edmonton
did and what the rest of canada can
learn from it back to you krista hessie
in toronto thanks to watch christa's
full report on changing the mindset to
better prepare our communities tune into
the new reality saturday at 8 pm on
global
let the games begin ahead the
festivities and the faults as the winter
olympics kick off
[Music]
with today's opening ceremonies the
beijing winter olympics are officially
underway even before the official start
these games had already seen daring
leaps of faith and skating in circles
both on the ice and in the political
arena as ross lord reports the big
question now is whether organizers can
keep these games on track
on the surface the beijing olympics are
off to a dazzling start
but this olympic dream has until now
been more like a nightmare from calls to
scrap or postpone the games to a
widespread diplomatic boycott to the
ever-present threat of covet-19
outbreaks at least two athletes who
would have been flag bearers at the
opening ceremony were kept out because
of positive covet tests including
american bob's letter alana myers-taylor
competition in some events had already
started with chinese officials hoping
worldwide tv audiences take notice after
they sunk billions of dollars into these
games but for many watching these
olympics as strictly a sporting
competition is hard to do as hard as
untangling political positions
canada the u.s and japan are among the
nations keeping diplomatic officials
home to protest china's human rights
record
at the same time they're contributing to
the game's prestige and success by
sending a full contingent of athletes
this former canadian olympian says
despite that contradiction the games are
worthwhile the olympics brings everybody
together
uh under a common batter and in a
difficult world that's um
that's a lot better than a kick in the
teeth
and with the performances that we will
see they're going to create moments of
incredible surprise and joy a notable
exception to the diplomatic boycott
russia president vladimir putin took in
the opening festivities a show of
respect to his chinese allies but nbc's
cameras caught putin appearing to doze
off when the team from ukraine entered a
moment that's already generating
intrigue at a time when russian troops
are poised to invade ukraine
saturday marks the first full day of
events and the first awarding of medals
athletes from 91 nations competing
through february 20th it's unclear to
anyone if these olympics will be a
diversion from the pandemic and
international strife or an unwelcome
reminder
ross lord global news
the former wife of jeff bezos mackenzie
scott donated more than 130 million u.s
dollars to a charity supporting
underprivileged students this week her
latest generous donation comes as her
ex-husband is making news in a different
way with his new super yacht as redmond
shannon tells us a famous dutch bridge
is apparently in his way
the historic center of rotterdam was
almost totally destroyed during the nazi
bombing of may 1940
today one of the few landmarks left that
predates the war is this bridge
the distinctive koningshaven to hef to
locals with its rising center trains no
longer use it but it stands as a
towering monument or has until now if it
was just anybody
but this is the world's richest man that
wants to mess with our monument that's
just not okay amazon founder jeff bezos
is reportedly having this super yacht
the largest of its type in the world
built upstream this week it emerged the
bridge will need to be disassembled
temporarily to get bezos's big boat out
to sea i really felt a feeling of
disbelief when i first heard it city
councilor stefan lewis says the plan
must have been known about months ago
before the yacht construction began but
we know that the super yachts are
getting bigger and bigger so are we
going to take this bridge apart every
time such a super yacht needs to pass
through if he likes it
why why not weiner zittleman has written
books about the super rich and our
attitudes toward them i can say the
feeling that someone has about people
like shift basis i can tell you whether
you will be successful or
not successful in life so don't expect
bezos to worry about rubbing up
rotterdam residents the wrong way what
might the neighbor say to this or that i
think this is not the typical question
of successful people the city's mayor
says no permit has been granted for the
bridge work yet bezos would be on the
hook for any associated costs but for a
man worth nearly 200 billion dollars
it's likely to be chump change redmond
shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
friday i'm eric sorenson tonight's your
canada is carbonier newfoundland and
labrador
there are beautiful spots all over
canada email them to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]